i look at my kids in my time machine
they're going in the future for me i see
my children and i [ __ ] i'm just like
astonished like you know it's like i
can't believe like what the hell is
going on like
i remember being that now i'm watching
them do the same things i didn't act the
same way and you could tell the tantrums
oh yeah i used to do that [ __ ] yeah i
used to lay on the [ __ ] middle of the
floor
that's totally out of their mind um
[ __ ] special ed and everything that's
me
oh man
special that was a good time beautiful
right beautiful bunch of good people get
your milk and cookies
milk and cookies of course
the breakfast oh you got signed up for
the early breakfast that's it this is
what i find is so interesting people in
brooklyn are only people proud to be in
a special end i've never heard people
especially that mms let people know
they're special that we don't even hey i
wasn't speculating we did this that's
right cooking the milk that's a good
that's a big accomplishment
yeah from special ed to here right look
at that you know what i mean a serious
[ __ ] holy [ __ ]
just remembering like junior high school
and high school and just all that stuff
i'm scared to come to school because
somebody's gonna kick your ass
that's brooklyn okay i ain't going to
school today i'm staying outside i only
go to school for lunch lunch time we get
the food and get out
there was always something going on man
yeah
it was always something [ __ ] crazy yo
well i finally keep you got five things
no if i anything i find i keep
asked somebody yeah a dollar every day
yo let me get a dollar please oh yo let
me get a dollar let me get a dollar
always for the [ __ ] i always borrowed
a dollar from the same kid every day
i must owe that kid like 400 dollars he
kept it but he left that a lot of money
he kept giving it yeah he kept giving it
to me he didn't care a lot of people
would ask him to borrow a dollar he was
that guy oh he's the one yeah he was the
one he was
he was definitely the one i was that guy
just being picked on in school [ __ ]
took my glasses and put it in the gaff
tank of a [ __ ] truck
just for not just a man
yeah man
yeah that's not a nice [ __ ] thing
kids were [ __ ] leaning back getting
bullied yeah
bullied for being fat
you need to call me fat [ __ ] money to
[ __ ] push you in the bush
i'm getting pushed in the bush i got
pushed in the bush several times they
they may have some [ __ ] over
behind you and oh yeah
that [ __ ] game
yeah slapping the slap boxing game [ __ ]
slap and then [ __ ] run the way you
got to run you just slapped me and now
you're running
i want to get off yeah let me get one
off now let me get a hit off
you got to catch me yeah and you know
i'm not gonna catch you because i'm fat
and i can't [ __ ] catch you
[Music]